welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boston hawkeye episode 5 is expected to
be a major game changer that blows up
social media at least according to the
directors not that we've ever been led
astray by a marvel disney plus caster
crew before
but a new promo for the next episode is
giving us a look at what that might be
let's take a look i made a whole lot of
enemies
tracksuit mafia
even a black widow that doesn't sound
good this holiday season tell the boss
christmas came early hawkeye
he's on everyone's list
[Music]
hi
i'm here to kill him
clint barton
we need a ton of triggers
marvel studios hawkeye only on disney
plus so much of this new footage centers
around a swanky christmas party at 30
rockefeller center which i assume is
that bishop company holiday party that
eleanor teased in episode four i need
your help with a few decisions on the
bishop holiday party i go i don't i
don't think i'm in the middle of it come
on kay you're great at this sort of
thing
a company holiday party around christmas
eve set in an iconic tower that a major
media company uses as a base of
operations this is exactly the same
setup of die hard a movie that appeared
as an easter egg in episode four as one
of the dvds kate brings to watch with
clint diehard takes place in nakatomi
tower which in real life is fox plaza in
the century city part of los angeles and
the hawkeye series has clearly been
influenced by die hard as a christmas
action comedy and now it looks like
they're gonna totally restage the
nakatomi tower incident at 30 rock
instead despite their spat at the end of
episode 4 kate and clint will join each
other in attendance at this party and
then the track suits are going to show
up the windows are going to get shot out
and then in this new promo cazzy says
tell the boss christmas came early by
the boss he's clearly referring to
springsteen i mean with all those next
tattoos you know cassie's from jersey i
don't know i'm kidding he's referring to
uncle and uncles probably referring to
wilson fisk kingpin aka vincent
d'onofrio which to me would be the only
reveal i could see actually being big
enough to truly break social media my
guess is that clint and kate are
captured once more by cassie in the
tracksuits along with that recovered
rolex that kate stole from maya lopez's
apartment but i don't know why cazzy
would be so proud since those two and
the watch were already in their
possession and they essentially lost all
of those through carelessness so would
they really go back to kingpin and be
like christmas please don't kill us i
have speculated that that rolex could
contain some information about laura
barton's past as like a
mockingbird-esque agent or even a secret
scroll asset list but if we were talking
about a list of names in hiding around
the world elena belovo was trusted with
a list of widows that natasha downloaded
from the red room server at the end of
black widow that red vial of widow
antidote spray could connect to the red
face of the rolex and now it does sound
like cassie has acquired something new
that they didn't have before that could
be elena and her asset list of
programmable widow assassins which is
also something you can imagine kingpin
loving to get his hands on episode 5 is
looking like a major black widow elena
episode there's a shot of her extending
her black widow baton another shot shows
her catching a bottle of sriracha like
gina davis in a league of their own she
wears a similar but different yellow and
black checkerboard button up like that
yellow and black plaid that she was
wearing in the black widow post credit
scene when val sent her on this mission
to kill clint she also wears a number of
pins different ones from the post credit
scene but you know she's got a look and
she's sticking to it in what i assume
will be a yelena flashback she's back in
her white tactical suit that she wore in
the third act of black widow in a new
mission in some fancy mansion could this
be a home of wilson fisk did she make an
enemy of the kingpin well she does have
a new vest since she did give her favor
wanted natasha at the end of black widow
and natasha went on to wear that
infinity war she is tackling some woman
to the ground it's hard to tell who this
woman is vanessa or with her blonde hair
at first i wondered power broker sharon
carter i don't know the fact that elena
isn't essentially in her same clothes at
the end of black widow she could just
still be on that mission to track down
other widows who are programmed the
sleeper agents in place around the world
and then trying to blast them with a
fresh spray of that antidote in order to
free them you can see as she's coming
down the stairs there is someone else
behind her and then in the shot of her
tackling that woman there is another
woman in black running up to her from
the other side of that room that woman
looks like one of the other widows who
are suited up in black tactical gear
that elena left with at the end of the
black widow film so she's got like a
squad you know to be honest with you i
stayed up really late writing this video
sometimes i like to stay up super late
finishing videos like this but then i
want to sleep in and no matter how hard
i pull those curtains closed it is just
hard to get my bedroom super dark
especially with all the little electric
lights that have been populating our
living spaces surge protectors phone
chargers the government surveillance
they think i didn't notice well that is
where the blue blocks remedy sleep mask
comes in handy we knew blue blocks from
their blue light blocking glasses but
their sleep mask goes farther and blocks
out 100
of light for better sleep it's very soft
and it has adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for people who sleep on their
belly on their side and on their back
you can fully open your eyes while
wearing it and nothing my eyes are open
right now i'm watching you does it creep
you out i mean obviously it doesn't
creep me out you've watched me whether
it's you or the government but the
watching persists it's creepy to whisper
when everything around you is pitch
black
this thing is awesome for improving
sleep meditation napping and travel like
i love using it when i want to sleep in
or grab a nap during the day when i want
to try to sleep on an airplane and the
idiots won't close their windows blue
blocks ships worldwide and has other
great products like red light therapy
devices so go to blueblocks.com new
rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 that's blueblox.com
b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use
coupon code new rockstars to save 20 but
elena is also confirmed to be part of
that 30 rock battle we saw the baton
shot and now we see her and clint
fighting on the ice rink in front of the
building we know from the other footage
that this battle is going to spill out
on the ice clint mentions them needing a
ton of trick arrows for whatever this
operation is and we see a new one a
trick arrow that inflates as a giant
airbag that blows everyone off their
feet there's also this interesting
moment when three arrows are fired at
the same time if you look closely each
one of these arrows are different
remember clint made a big deal about the
limitations of these trick arrows and
how new shafts can't just be bought in
stores how do we get more trick arrows
well there are no more trick arrows
like in the world
basically have a few more trick arrow
heads
you can't just put them on any shaft you
know other promo footage showed clint
wiring together some new arrowhead on
one of his arrow shafts i think he's
working on one of the three that we see
here started on the left that one
actually looks like a shaft made it from
a flat wooden stake and its tip is
dipped in something clint and kate were
talking about a complicated trick that
would require a wooden shaft it's not
impossible the first arrow you release
just has to be wood so when you release
the second one splits it right up the
middle
i call [ __ ] i've tried it well i've
done it a few times it seemed like clint
was talking about that classic robin
hood trick of double bulls eyeing a
target but in this case the wooden arrow
may be a kind of electrical conductor on
the tip of it that might not go through
the wood of the shaft or maybe they're
trying to kill a vampire by the way i
know i've said tip versus shaft a lot
it's hard to say that with a straight
face so hard but onto this middle arrow
in addition to the thickest head
like the pymtech tip it also has a
propeller-like tail that recalls that
modification kate made to her arrow in
the first episode that allowed it to
sail and bring down obadiah stain's bell
tower the third meanwhile has the most
rounded tip of the three considering the
shot that we have seen in promos before
of the blue electrical current jumping
among the flagpoles i'm wondering if
clint might use some of the tech from
the black widow widow's bite a red
version of which was used on him by
elena bulova and then he yanked off its
neck that would still leave that node
still in his possession and it may be
able to repurpose for something else if
the propeller like tail tells us that
this is all kate's idea might be the
first bit of collaboration between kate
bishop hawkeye cb2 i'm just trying it
out for a second in your elena beloved
black widow and r2
as this next generation of avengers form
their growing team but in terms of what
this mission is it seems like clint and
kate are going to try to trap everyone
in the track suit operation with jack at
this party all in one basket to turn
into the authorities expose the
corruption that jack is associated with
but i assume what they're gonna find out
is that kate's mom eleanor is very much
a mastermind of that operation and that
she works for a boss a boss being
kingpin it's gonna be a lot harder for
them to bring down this network than
they think ah this is some christmas to
support our channel check out some of
our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis and
breakdowns of everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you